So it's 9:00 AM.
So good morning from the west coast.
I'm Alex Co-Director of the BD2K Center's
Coronation
Center.
And so this morning, I have the pleasure of
introducing Dr. Carl Kesselman, the speaker
for today's BD2K
guide to the fundamentals of data science.
Dr. Carl Kesselman is the Dean's Professor
at the University of
Southern California, and Director of the Informatics
Systems Research Division at the Information
Science
Institute, ISI.
He's well known for his work in group computing,
and has led several NAIH data consortia over
the years.
One of
Dr. Kesselman's more recent interests is collection
and creation of digital asset management systems
for scientific
discovery.
And in this light, he's going to be talking
today about fair principles, and its application
in daily tasks.
For those listening in, if you have questions
for Dr. Kesselman, please type them in the
chat box.
And if we have
time at the end, we'll go through some of
them.
Dr. Kesselman, it's great to have you speaking
with us this
morning.
And I'm looking forward to hearing more of
your perspective on [INAUDIBLE] implementation.
The floor
is yours.
Great, thank you very much.
So I thought we would start by just outlining
the goals here for the talk today.
I
thought it might be interesting to-- I'm not
going to focus so much on directly the research
that I'm doing and the
details of some of the things that we're doing
here, with respect to BD2K.
But I thought it would be useful to maybe
talk a little more generally about the role
of data in scientific discovery, and some
trends that are emerging with
how to manage data in the process of scientific
discovery.
Particularly, a lot of it's driven by BD2K
and big data.
And my experience has been that a lot of scientists
who are
doing even data analysis, data generation,
doing lots of data-driven science, there's
been a lot of work and a of
thinking in how one should go about managing
that process.
And I realize that, especially people who
are more
domain-oriented along the biomedical discovery
tend not to be aware of some of the thinking
and ideas that have
gone on.
And so I thought I would spend some time reviewing
background and trends of what's happening
in data
management that, I think, are going to be
especially relevant to this audience in kind
of your daily practice.
So what I hope to get out of this talk is--
I apologize if people in the audience actually
know this stuff already.
But
what I would hope we get out of this is some
recognition as to how to adapt your data management,
data
collection practices, especially driven by
data-oriented discovery and big data, and
how you might take away
some practical things, or at least some ways
to think about what you're doing that I think
it's important.
So that is
our goal.
And then I will show you some of the work
we've done that bring some of these ideas
to practice.
So with
that as kind of the goal with what I'd like
to achieve, let's proceed forward as following.
So I'd like to start actually with maybe an
existential question.
Take a step back.
What does it mean to have a
scientific result?
And maybe this is obvious.
But it's probably worth thinking a little
bit about.
So at a higher level, a scientific result
is something that other people know about.
So this is if a tree falls in the
forest that nobody knows about it, does it
actually fall?
So we are concerned about communication, sharing
the
results.
But more importantly, it's important that
others are able to validate that result.
And we can break that down into three things.
One is that we need to be able to reproduce
the method that was
used to create that result and achieve the
same answer so that we might be able to, in
some sense, repeat what
was being done.
We would also ideally like to cross-validate,
which is we would like to get the same result
using a
different method.
And that way, we know what we've determined
is actually true in some sense.
And then, ultimately, the result
should be something that we can reuse to create
a new method, and as a foundation for achieving
new scientific
results.
So hopefully, these observations should be
obvious to you.
And here's a nice quote from somebody who
was involved in the theory of science, which
is a non-reproducible single occurrences are
of no significance to
science.
So I want you to take this to heart.
If you produce a result, and it's not reproducible,
and it's a single occurrence,
this is scientifically irrelevant.
So we should all be saying, well, of course.
If we're doing science, the whole
purpose of science is to let people know what
we've done, and allow them to reproduce our
results.
So why are we even having this conversation?
Well, it turns out that even though this is
obvious, we're not
achieving this goal.
So here are some results from a science paper--
sorry, nature paper-- that was published in
2016.
And you actually don't have to go very far.
These things are showing up in the popular
literature.
There's articles on NPR and the BBC, and so
on, about the reproducibility of scientific
results.
And there's been
studies that show that one in 10 papers, the
results of one in 10 papers can be reproduced.
So in May 2016, there
was a little article in Nature where they
went off and surveyed 1,500 researchers.
And here's the direct quote from the Nature
paper.
More than 70% of researchers have tried and
failed to
reproduce other scientist's experiments.
And, more tellingly, this is really damning,
more than half were able to
reproduce their own experiments.
So even though the previous slide should be,
well, of course, that's obvious,
when we look at what's going on in practice,
that's not what's happening.
So not only can't we reproduce other people's
results.
We cannot even reproduce our own results.
So let's look at
a breakdown.
So this is-- in Nature, the question is phrased
is, is there a crisis?
And what we see is that, depending on the
degree of crisis, 80% of the scientists surveyed
said there is a crisis.
Actually, this is 90% said there's a crisis
in
reproducibility.
Over half of scientists surveyed said there's
a significant crisis.
Those are pretty dramatic words to say there's
a crisis.
And if we were to look at, again from the
survey, they
asked, what is things that contribute to this
crisis?
And what we see is that there's a lot of issues
that contribute.
And so we can't put our fingers on any one
thing.
So it goes everything from bad luck, to fraud,
to cherry picking
your data.
But I think there's kind of two things here
that I'd like to focus on that are especially
relevant to be
BD2K.
So one is the methods, or code, are unavailable.
So we can't reproduce, because we don't have
the documentation of the methods or code in
a meaningful way.
And then, secondly, lack of availability of
data, and I'm going to interpret this a little
more broadly than just raw
data.
It can be just general lack of access to data.
And actually these are two pretty significant
factors showing up kind of at the 80% level,
in terms of the results of
the reporting of this survey.
And so, again, there's a lot of reasons why
we can't reproduce things.
I was a little
surprised to learn that major source of lack
of reproducibility of biomedical results is
bad anti-bodies.
They just don't work.
And as a result of that, the NIH is requiring
anti-body [INAUDIBLE] validation procedures
to
be included as part of proposals that are
being submitted.
But we're not necessarily talking about wet
lab
experiments here.
How are these things, the notion of reproducibility,
relevant to us or in the BD2K community?
Well, I think what we need to think of is
that since we are, in many cases, analyzing
data, or we're doing things
computationally, really what we're doing is
we are conducting experiments with data.
And we need to think about
the same kind of experimental rigor that takes
place if we were sitting in a bench, or running
a clinical trial.
That
same kind of rigor, and experimental design,
and documentation needs to take place when
we think about the
generation, consumption, and analysis of our
data.
And I would argue that as we move to an increasingly
computational-based environment, and as we're
being
overwhelmed by data and new analytic methods,
which is the underpinning of the whole idea
behind BD2K, the
role of data in either the reproducibility,
or lack of reproducibility, in our experiment
is only going to get more
important.
So let's try to break this down a little bit,
and think about, what does it mean to have
reproducibility in data?
What
kinds of characteristics would you like?
What can we do to enhance our reproducibility
around data?
So you can think about this in kind of splitting
it up into-- I've got two main issues of points
that I think are worth
thinking about.
One is at any level, data is only going to
be useful, just having the ones and zeros
for the numbers,
in and of itself is essentially of no use.
And if I give you a pile full of numbers,
those are essentially meaningless to
me.
And the only way that there is going to be
meaning or useful, the data will have utility,
is if I can figure out some
way, kind of where the data is so I can get
my hands on the numbers, what it is, what
these numbers represent,
and then ultimately how it was created.
So if you think about it, only if I know how
to get my hands on it, what it is
that I'm trying to get my hands on, and how
it was produced, then if I don't have that,
then this whole notion of
reproducibility is really a nonstarter.
So we need to think-- and I'm sure, again,
if we think about it maybe we're all doing
some of this in our daily
practice.
But I think there's value in thinking about
these issues a little more explicitly, and
thinking about how does
this structure the way we set up our computational
laboratory?
The second thing I'd like to comment on is
when
we think about reproducibility of data, I
think there is a tendency to focus on publication
as the main artifact for
which there has to be reproducibility.
So we think about, when we send that thing
off to Nature, then we have to document what
we've been doing so
our protocol could be reproduced.
Then, computationally, I think we often think
that way.
And in many of our
experiments, we think that way.
Now, if you think about it, though, when we
design a clinical trial, it's actually, in
some sense, the exact opposite.
A
clinical trial, we explicitly lay out the
protocol, and the analysis, and the sample
size, and the selection criteria, and
all that, kind of explicitly ahead of time.
And data is collected with that in mind.
Now, of course, that's a very rigid and painful
process of doing that.
It's not conducive to more experimental,
discovery-based innovation.
But there's maybe some lessons to be learned
from that.
So my point is, as we think
about reproducibility , the reproducibility
is not something we tack on at the end when
we're ready to publish.
Reproducibility is something that has to imbue
the entire experimental process, whether those
experiments
involve growing cells, or whether those experiments
involve writing code.
We need to be thinking about
reproducibility throughout the entire life
cycle of our data.
That's everything from the initial acquisition,
whether that's experimental acquisition or
that's acquisition by making
simulated data, that has to be applied at
every step in the process, that involves computing
an analysis.
And then
ultimately, at the end of the day, that also
involves thinking about, at the point of publication,
how do we promote
reproducibility at that point there?
So that's kind of a little bit about maybe
the philosophical framework in which
we're starting with.
So how can we bring that to bear?
And how does that impact us in our daily practice?
Well, I'd like to start-- I'm
going to get a little more abstract.
But I'm going to split the conversation here
into-- actually I think I've said here-- two
things, process and product.
So I would just like to review process a little
bit.
And then we'll talk about product.
So process is more about how we generate our
data product.
And then product is we'll talk about characteristics
of that actual data.
So in preparing for this talk, I actually
wasn't aware of this paper.
But I found this reference to a very nice
paper here, which I think the paper outlined
10 simple rules for
reproducible computational research.
And looking through these rules, it's actually
quite good.
And I think it behooves all of us to look
at this checklist, and think about it.
And when you do your computational
work, when you're doing your big data analytics,
which parts of these things do you actually
do in your daily
practice?
If I have a little time towards the end, I'll
show you some tools that we build, and we
use in our daily
practice, that actually make it really simple
to follow most of these 10 rules.
So that's kind of the work that we do, is
how do we make sure that everyone can easily
follow these rules?
But
even in the absence of tools, like the ones
that we built which I think are pretty spiffy,
but even in the absence of
these tools, these are lessons that you can
follow every day.
And, again, maybe some of them are obvious.
And, hopefully, many of you who are listening
to this already do this.
And if you don't, you should think about,
which one of these things could I start doing
tomorrow because they'll impact my reproducibility?
So it's simple
things, like track of how you produced every
result.
So that could mean write it down.
That could mean create a spreadsheet.
That could mean use provenance tracking tools,
like Python notebooks or
R notebooks.
Those are, potentially, ways of keeping track
of how data was produced.
But then you also need to
be a little bit careful.
Like, don't go back and rewrite cells previously.
So you still need to kind of keep track of
things.
Avoid manual data
steps.
Thing you do manually are hard to reproduce
and impose errors.
Keep track of all the things that you use.
External programs, keep track of the version
numbers that you generate
the data with.
And for things you develop yourself, please
use get Git Hub or some other version control
system to
keep track of what you're doing so you know
how your data was produced.
Three is quite interesting.
I think it was fairly widely published that
there was a bug discovered in one of the
standard FMRI analysis laboratories that was
producing wrong results.
So he bug was fixed.
But there is a large number of publications
that were created using the software model
for doing analysis, for
which there was a bug, for which we have no
idea which papers are now invalid, because
we don't know the
version number that was used to produce those
results.
So that's an example of three.
Now, number five is going
to this whole life cycle thing.
Don't throw away the intermediate results.
Everything is important.
Every step along the way is important.
Storage
is cheap these days.
So keep all the intermediate results.
Don't just keep the final result.
Six, I'm a little less interested in.
If you're doing random things, you want to
know how your random number
generator was seated.
Number seven, always keep your raw data.
Don't just give us the plot.
Give us the data
behind the plot, presumably with all the history
of how it was generated.
Allow you to kind of zoom in and out of your
data.
That's number eight.
And number nine is, if you analysis or text,
you always want to connect them to the underlying
results to the data.
We're going to talk next about how one
might go about connecting textual statements
like publications to the underlying results.
And then 10, we're also
going to talk about shortly, which is we need
to provide access to the scripts, runs, and
results, because
transparency is the key to reproducible science.
So those are some things that impact process,
how do we go about producing our data?
Again, I think there's
some takeaway here.
If you're not checking off you know seven,
eight, or nine of these things in what you're
doing
today, go back after this lecture.
And think about, what can I do to increase
the number of these things that I'm
doing?
So now, let's talk a little bit about the
product itself, and the data.
What properties would we like the data to
have
that come out of, for example, these 10 simple
rules, that are going to promote this notion
of reproducibility so that
we can find data, so that we know how it was
produced, so that we can have a chance of
regenerating the
method, and then so we can reuse that data
as the foundation to do new things?
Now, what's come out of kind of the community
of people who care about these things, every
day they come in
and out, and think about data, and running
repositories curating data?
What's emerged actually out of an
organization called Force 11 is this notion
that data should have some basic properties.
And say that we want our
data to be findable, accessible, interoperable,
and reusable.
And I'm going to go through each of these
things in more detail.
But these are called the fair criteria, or
fair guiding
principles.
So what we would look like is our data to
be fair.
Now, if you haven't heard of these fair principals,
you have now.
And you should be aware of the fact that these
are increasing traction across the two things
you probably do care about.
One is that the NIH is increasingly
adopting and pushing fair principles, and
driving that in to the grants, and into the
repositories where you're
required to deposit your data when you're
done.
The other thing is that scientific journals
are increasingly concerned about reproducibility,
and imposing elements
of fair principles on the submissions to these
journals.
So in spite of the fact that it's the right
thing to do, there are
also kind of self-serving reasons why you
want your data to be fair, because you're
going to need it to get money.
And you're going to need it to publish your
results.
And the reason why it's the right thing to
do is because those results you get are going
to be higher impact, and
have a better chance of being correct.
And I'd also like to make the point that,
often when we talk about fair data,
it's a trap to think that, oh, that's just
something for the repository people to worry
about.
That's just something
that I need to worry about when I publish
my data.
I think the benefit of fair data applies throughout
the process, from creating the data to the
point of publication.
So
fair data helps us achieve the 10 simple rules.
And if you remember back in the earlier slide,
lack of reproducibility
was due to me not being able to reproduce
my own results.
And so if we think about fair as something
that is good
throughout the process, we're going to go
after that issue of, can I even reproduce
my own results?
So what's good for the general community at
the point of publication, at some level is
good for you as you're doing
computational science.
So what I'm going to do is I'm going to drill
down.
And we're going to look at what the
definition of fair actually means.
And in order to understand-- so FAIR is written
by kind of this data curation, data library,
data management
community.
And I'm assuming most of the people on this
call aren't active participants in that community.
So
there's some jargon or some background stuff
that I think that you need to have a basic
understanding of in order
to actually read the FAIR principles and understand
them.
So if you'll indulge me for a few minutes,
what I'd like to do is just review some of
these background concepts that
maybe you're familiar with maybe or not.
And if you're not familiar with them, you
don't have to be experts in this.
But you should be aware of these ideas, and
have a vague idea of what they mean, because
I think they're pretty
important.
And, again, they'll help you structure your
data methods so that they're going to be more
robust.
And they'll be
more oriented towards FAIR.
And you'll have better reproducibility of
results.
So the two concepts I'd like to review before
we dive into the FAIR principles are the notion
of metadata, and the
notion of persistent identifiers, because
these two concepts kind of permeate the FAIR
principles.
So let's start
with metadata.
So I'm actually going to take a little step
back.
And, again, this is something that maybe you
do implicitly in your
work.
It's always good to think about these ideas
explicitly, because they help you design better,
and have better
experimental design around computational experiments.
So I want to introduce, if you're not familiar
with this idea,
the notion of a data model.
So a data model, kind of in the information
sciences literature, is something that, basically,
describes the structure
of the data, and the relationship between
big pieces of your data.
So a data model at a high level talks about
the
things we care about.
We care about samples, and measurements, and
essays, and images, and sequences.
Those are examples of things we care about.
And how in attributes of those things-- so
what are the attributes
that describe a sequencing experiment, for
example?
And then also, we often don't think about
this, but the
connection between them.
How is a sample related to observations on
that sample?
How does a simulation run relate to an input
data file?
So it's things.
Sometimes we call those entities.
It's attributes, or properties, of those things,
and relationships
between those things.
And so if we have this underlying notion of
a data model, which describes kind of the
structure of the information,
another term people often use is that's a
knowledge model.
Which kind of represents the knowledge, the
connection, the structure, of what we care
about.
So the term metadata, which I'm sure you've
all heard of, is
really just-- so we often say metadata is
data about the data.
So what does that mean?
So it's a structured set of attributes that
describe our data.
In other words, it's the data
model.
So the metadata is, basically, the data model
that describes the structure and contents
of our data.
So when we think about metadata, what we first
need to do is think about, what's our metadata?
What are the
things that I care about?
How do I describe them?
And how are they connected?
And then I can take those descriptions, and
use that to both find data that I'm interested
in, and figure out what's
in there so I can reuse it.
Now, there are many different ways we can
create these models, and ways of notating
these things.
So you might have heard or a lot about these
things.
So things like the entity relation model is
an example of a way we might describe this.
Or the resource description
framework is another example.
So these are common tools used for creating
data models, which means that
these then become tools by which we create
metadata.
So let me just give you a little example.
So this is an example from one of the repositories
that I'm responsible for.
So this FaceBase.
So it's a repository for looking at a cranial
facial dysmorphia.
And it's fairly broad.
We've got imaging data.
We've got kind of more facial morphology.
We've got RNA sequence data, gene
expression data.
We've got micro CT, all kinds of things.
So here on the left is a picture of the simplified
view of our data model.
And notice it's structured.
So we have the idea of the project, which
is creating multiple datasets.
Each dataset might have a sample.
For each sample, we have multiple assays.
Each assay could have one or
more files.
Or we could just have files that directly
attach to a data set.
So this is our data model.
If you look at the right hand side of the
picture, you see a slightly more detailed
view of
this.
So you'll notice we have now four types of
assays-- imaging, clinical, bioinformatic,
and enhancer assays.
We have lots of different types of files.
So we can have band files, TIFF files, et
cetera.
So this is this notion of
data model.
So when we talk about metadata in this context,
essentially what we're doing now is for each
of these
boxes, we have a set of properties or attributes
that describe these things.
And that now becomes our metadata.
So for project, we might have something like
the project name.
We might
have the principal investigator.
For file, we might have the data type, the
file format, the date the file was obtained,
the instrument it was obtained from.
So that's an example, now, of our metadata
and data model.
So that's concept one that you should have
some familiarity and comfort with.
The second concept I want to
introduce is the notion of an identifier.
And on the material I'm presenting now, there's
a number of papers that
are out there.
The material I'm showing now is from a very
nice kind of blog post called Bad Identifiers
of the
Potholes of the Information Superhighway.
So an identifier in it's most basic is nothing
more than a name for someone.
So if I have something that I care
about, it's often useful and very important
to be able to name that thing in a convenient
way.
And there's lots of
different ways I can name things.
So it turns out, if you think about this for
a while, there are lots of reasons why you
might want to do that, and
characteristics I might want to have on that
name.
So this cartoon here gives you an example
of some of the
reasons why I might want a convenient name,
and some of the properties of that name.
And some of these maybe you've already run
across in your own.
I'm sure probably everyone on this seminar
has
probably made up names.
And they might be bad names.
Or they might be good names.
So let's look at some of these properties.
And this cartoon is basically showing the
use of the name from several
perspectives.
So from the basic researcher, if I want to
reproduce something and you get different
results, well,
maybe I've actually got the wrong physical
thing that I'm trying to reproduce the result
from.
Maybe the mouse has
got a different genotype.
Maybe I'm actually using a different antibody.
So how do I know that I actually used the
same stuff, or used the
same program, or produced the same answers
that another investigator did?
So having a robust name could help
that.
If you've got two published paper letters,
and they're using the same dataset, and the
same genes, and the
same analysis, how do I know if I've used
that?
I've done an analysis with a standard piece
of software.
How do I
know if these two people who produced the
result actually used the same thing?
So naming is important for doing
that.
We'll skip the [INAUDIBLE] dependent perspective.
I don't think there's too many physicians
on this call.
But
there's plenty of bioinformatics researchers
here.
So how many times do we all see broken links?
We say, oh, here's the name of this thing.
Here's the URL on the website.
We go to use it.
And it doesn't work
anymore.
I can tell you as the operator of repositories,
before we took over people were just embedding
links to the website
in their published papers.
So you go to try to reference something that's
in this published paper.
And you get a
can't find error.
Did they use the same protocol that I used?
Was the same algorithm used?
The same code used one when they
published the result?
And then, finally, this last thing, if things
are named, then I have a better chance of
not only reusing them, but then
tracking that other people are using them.
So we want to report results.
So these are all reasons why we might
want to have a name.
So names can be tricky.
I mean, if we think through them, there can
be a lot of complexity.
We have to be really
kind of explicit as to what we intend the
name to be used for, and how we create this
thing.
So here's a real world
example.
There is an ID 9606, which, depending on how
you're interpreting it could be everything
from the name of a
species, to a name of a bacteria, to a certain
chemical.
So all these things have been assigned ID
number 9606.
So that's not a very good name.
If I assign this thing, and I say, use 9606,
and you don't even know what it's referring
to.
And this is a real world
example.
And if you look at this paper that I referred
to, they go into more detail about this particular
example.
So what are some properties that we would
like names to have?
So, in general, we would like a name to be
globally unique so that one name refers to
one thing.
So this is this notion of globally unique.
And this is what we call an identifier.
So the name refers to just one thing.
That name that I can use that name to
somehow find, or locate, or get my hands on
that thing.
So that's something you'll refer to as being
actionable.
And that would be great if that name always
worked at some level so that we could always
use this name, and find
something out about the thing that we're referring
to.
And the term we use for that is we call those
identifiers
persisted or permanent.
So one way to think of this in the physical
world is that we go to a library, and each
book
has an ISBN number.
And that ISBN number always refers to that
book.
And even if I can't get a hold of the book,
at least I can get
some information about that book, like where
in the shelf it will be located if it exists,
who the author was, when it
was published, things like that.
Now, you've probably in your practice seen
things like this thing in citations, or
papers, or when you go this thing that says
DOI.
That stands for Digital Object Identifier.
So that's an example of an identifier that
has these properties.
So there's
this whole kind of structure and infrastructure
that's been built to make sure that those
DOIs are globally unique.
They only refer to one thing.
They're actionable, which is I can use that
DOI.
I can plug it into a web browser, and get
that information about
what it's referring to.
And there's this whole financial business
structure built up so that I'm guaranteed
that a DOI
always works.
So the idea is 100 years from now, I should
be able to resolve a DOI, and get back information
about that data, or
that publication, even if that data or republication
no longer exists.
And DOIs are increasingly being used now not
just for publications, but for data as well.
So that's an example of an identifier.
And here's just a picture.
If we look at this, this is an example of
a citation.
Hopefully, you can see my mouse right
here.
So if you see this thing here, that thing
that starts with HTTP://zfin.org/, then ZFIN,
colon, and all that stuff.
So that is the example of a persistent identifier
that uniquely identifies a piece of data in
the ZFIN data repository.
And that's what's called actionable.
So those are, I could type that into a web
browser.
And I will get back information about that
particular piece of
data.
And this other one here is another example
of a type of identifier.
So this is an identifier that's actually not
resolved, or turned into an action by ZFIN.
But it's by the California Digital Libraries
is actually resolving that.
So that's our background information.
So now we can look in a little more detail.
When we say something is clear,
what does that mean?
So what does it mean for something could be
findable?
So for something to be findable, intuitively
that means we know something about it.
We can locate it.
Out of this
vast sea of data, we need to be able to actually
discover which piece of data we're interested
in.
And so this is going to focus on two things.
One of which is we're going to have some metadata
that describes this
thing so that we know we've got something
that's interesting.
And we need to name that metadata.
So we're going to name that are there with
a global unique persistent identifier.
So I'm going to have an identifier.
It's going to name a collection of metadata.
That metadata, point two, is going to describe
what's in our data with
rich metadata, and interpret rich metadata
to say I've got an interesting data model
that describes what I've got.
That metadata is then searchable.
So we've taken it.
And we've registered it.
And so we can look for things, based
on characteristics of the data.
And then, finally, that the data itself has
a persistent globally unique identifier.
So we can name and refer to the
metadata that we used to describe the data.
We can name and refer to that data, both globally,
and persistently,
and uniquely.
And then we've got a rich model that allows
us to find things that we're interested in
So that's the notion of findable.
So kind of takeaway lessons here is, as you're
creating data in intermediate
products and publications, think about, can
I give it a name that's unique?
Can I describe it with metadata?
Should
I name the metadata?
naming Should I be naming the data?
How should I search for it?
And then you might want to think about findability
in the tools that you use everyday.
So what is my metadata?
Is it
the file name?
Is it a spreadsheet?
Do I think about, explicitly, what attributes
I want to have for this thing so that I have
a model?
Or do I just kind of
make stuff up when I stick it in the file
name?
So those are all things we can take away on
a daily basis.
To be accessible, that has to do with, once
I've found it, can I get my hands on the numbers?
Can I got my hands
on the stuff I'm interested in?
And this speaks to this notion of open science,
and the notion that transparency is
good for reproducibility in science.
Of course, we all know that there are reasons
why not every piece of data can be accessible,
for IP reasons, for
privacy reasons, for data use agreement reasons.
But, in general, what we would like to say
is that at least the
metadata-- I'm talking about our results should
be retrievable.
Given the identifier for a collection of metadata,
I
should be able to use a standardized protocol
to get my hands on that metadata.
And these days, what that
means is I should be able to use the web protocols,
or HTTP, to retrieve the metadata in a way
that I can
interpret.
So that means it comes back not just in raw
text, but maybe structured using CSV format,
or JSON, or something
like that.
That the protocol is open, free, and universally
implementable-- so, again, that says something
like
HTTP.
That the protocol allows for authentication
and authorization where necessary-- so that
says we can
protect it.
And that we separate the notion of accessibility
of the metadata from the data-- so we should
be able to know
something about the existence of a piece of
data, and some level of the characteristics
of that data, even if we
can't access the data or know it's available.
So if you think about, if I go to [INAUDIBLE],
I can search and discover
what genotypes are available, even if I can't
get my hands on the genetic data.
And then these other things say,
and I should be able to go through something
like an HTTP protocol, and query that catalog,
and find this stuff.
I
shouldn't hide it behind proprietary information.
So, essentially, metadata should be free.
It should be widely accessible.
You should be able to get to it using
standard non-restricted protocols.
And then we can address the question as to
whether you get to the data or not.
To be interoperable, so we want the metadata
to be structured in a way that I can interpret
it.
And so what that
means is often, we're going to express metadata
using standard representations in things that
you've probably
heard this ontology term, or vocabulary.
So we're going to have standard ways of describing
the metadata, and
the relationship between the pieces of the
metadata.
We'll typically tend to use a formal way of
describing that.
So
things like earlier, I talked about entity
relation model.
Or more commonly, we use this thing called
the resource
description framework, or RDF, as a way of
describing our metadata.
And we might render that into lots of different
mechanisms maybe, or representations.
Maybe you've heard of this
thing called JSON LD.
So that would be an example of that.
And our metadata will refer, potentially,
to other
metadata.
So this is this notion that we're not going
to have everything in one metadata record.
We might refer off
to other pieces of metadata.
And so this allows us to get a description
of a piece of data, or even the data itself,
and to be able to interpret it so we know
if it's what we want, how it was created,
where it came from.
And, lastly, we want our data to be reusable.
So that means, first of all, we have to document
our data with
enough kind of details that are correct so
that we know we've got what we're interested
in.
We would like a clear
statement of reuse properties of that data.
So this is this notion of uses license.
So for example, Creative Commons is an example
of a usage license.
And so
you should declare that explicitly.
You want some history of how the metadata
and data were produced.
So that's this notion of provenance.
So you
want to know what protocols or methods were
used.
So you know if you should be able to use it.
And then, lastly, some of these things that
there are community standards that are defined
for these metadata
and data.
And you should adhere to that.
So, for example, geo, or encode define community
standards for RNC
data in how you should describe your RNC experiments.
So that's an example of the main relevant
community
standards for raw metadata.
So these are the ideas behind fair data principles.
And the low level details of this are maybe
not germane to you.
But I think it's worthwhile to keep these
ideas in the back of your mind as you're designing
your experiments and
designing your data, and adhere to them.
So let me just very briefly give you an example
of how we've applied some of these things
in the work we're doing
in our BD2K center.
So some tools for playing fair, just to give
you a hint for how you can apply some of these
things in practice.
So within the BDDS Center of Excellence, we've
developed three tools that help promote fair
data creation and
exchange.
And I'll just very briefly run through them.
So there are these things we call a Big Data
Bag, which promotes access and findability,
this thing called a
research object, which defines a metadata
model, and helps promote findability and interoperability,
and then
something we call a minimal identifier, which
meets a bunch of these permanent ID requirements
that show up in
fair documents.
So I'll just go through this very briefly
to give you just an idea of how some simple
things can help promote fair.
So
we've created a packaging format, or a way
of collecting a collection of related data,
and then describing that data
in ways that promote access and interoperability.
So in some sense, a BD Bag is nothing more
than a fancy zip
file, where we've enumerated the structure
and defined what needs to be in that zip file.
And one of the most important things we include
is what's called a manifest, which basically
lists the set of files
you expect to see, and records their contents
using checksums.
So a manifest lists all the contents and
checksums.
And then we've also designed this for big
data.
So it might include data that we don't actually
have available to us, but are referenced by
identifiers.
But we have
the ability to enumerate all of these potential
contents, and know exactly what should be
included in there.
So this
gives us a convenient way of collecting up
and exchanging data.
We use something called research objects,
which are rich metadata.
So we include this.
This is an example.
A
research object is basically a metadata model
in some vocabulary that's been designed to
support interoperability.
So this is an example of metadata using a
research object.
And what we see here is that, for example,
this is
defining a file type using the research object
form.
And so this is a format called JSON LB.
And this is using a RDF
underlying metadata model.
And then the last piece is we've created in
this structure that makes it really easy to
create permanent identifiers
for any arbitrary piece of data or intermediate
data.
So rather than you having to go and talk to
somebody, and
belong to an organization, and have somebody
make the DOI for you, which is like what we
have to do do now,
we've leveraged something operated by the
California Digital Library, and provided the
ability for you to just, at the
spur of the moment, create a unique identifier
for a piece of data, and to associate enough
metadata with it so you
know exactly what you're talking about, who
created it, and when it was created.
So now, you can resolve that.
And this is an example of where you get back
in following the fair principles.
We've
now taken this identifier.
We've resolved this back to a specific set
of metadata.
So let me just give you an example of how
we might bring this all together very quickly.
So here's a little use case
that we've done with the encode data.
So in this case, our primary data source isn't
code.
We want to do some
computation on data that exists in the code
repository.
And you can go to encode.
And you can search.
And you can get back a list of things.
And then you can go.
And
you can download each of these things and
store it in a local directory, and then hope
you've downloaded all the
right files.
Then if you want something else to reuse this
data, they have to go and re-download that
same set of files.
So
that, obviously, does not promote reproducibility.
So applying some fair principles to that,
we have used our tools
to basically take an encode search, and turn
that into one of our Bag structures.
So now, basically, we've enumerated all the
results.
We've captured metadata about all of the results.
We've then
associated a unique name to this collection.
And then we bind an identifier to that collection
which is actionable.
So now, I can use and exchange this identifier.
I can go and retrieve meditate about that
collection.
I can retrieve
that collection, and then use that to access
the data so that I know that I've accessed
exactly the right collection of
data, in exactly the right version of data.
So now, I have the ability to start to have
reproducibility by applying these
FAIR principles using these tools to computational
experiments that I might want to do on encode.
So I'm going to stop now.
That gives us a few minutes for questions.
So just to take away, that we should always
So I'm going to stop now.
That gives us a few minutes for questions.
So just to take away, that we should always
be concerned about reproducibility.
It's something that should inform your data
practice.
It's not that hard to introduce notions of
reproducibility into your analytic processes.
You should always use
version control.
You should always write scripts.
You should always keep your intermediate results.
You should always think about how you're going
to identify things in a unique way.
So we need to practice
computational processes that promote reproducibility.
And we should keep in the back of our mind
that, even if it's
just for ourselves or our immediate collaborators,
that we would always like our data to be findable,
accessible,
interoperable, and reproducible.
It's not just something we should care about
when we publish.
We should think about how we can do this every
day.
There are tools like the BD2K tools that help
you do that.
It doesn't have to be hard.
It's something that's just good to do.
And it's becoming increasingly something that
you're going to need for
funding and publication.
So whether you want to do it or not, you're
going to be forced to do it.
So with that, I'm going to stop.
There's just a few minutes for questions.
And thank you for your time, and
hopefully attention.
Thank you Dr. Kesselman, for this great talk.
So a couple questions, but first there's a
comment from the
audience, which was that in the discussion
of fair and data management and the data processes,
one of the sort
of underlooked resources that people often
fail to recognize as a great resource for
helping with a lot of these
processes are your librarian's.
So I think librarians, particularly at academic
medical centers and other universities,
are increasingly involved in the data management
processes of big data, and other sorts of
data repositories.
So
for those in the audience, and looking at
data management issues, I think going to your
librarian is certainly a
good thing, because they can also provide
a lot of insight.
So one question that has come up is one about
context.
And the use of data in terms of both primary
data and
secondary analysis.
So you sort of emphasized this at the beginning
of your talk, with respect to describing what
the data is, how to get to it, and the such.
But I think one of the challenges, particularly
in the biomedical space, is we often have
data sets where the data is
collected for primary use, such as maybe clinical
care or something else.
And then it's being accessed or analyzed
for secondary purposes.
And trying to understand what the context
is around the original intent of the data
is often
undocumented.
Do you have any thoughts on how FAIR, and
the annotation processes, and all that, can
sort of
be interwoven into that?
Yeah, I think that's a good question.
So secondary use is always a challenge.
So there are a couple of ways you
can approach that.
So one is to design-- depending on the recent
reproduction of the data, to design with
secondary use in mind.
And so for some things, like these repository
studies that I have, that is the primary motivation.
So we can do that
work upfront.
In terms of kind of serendipitous secondary
use, one would like to make the argument that
if you're
doing FAIR for your own primary use, that
that would allow, at some level of interpretation,
for secondary reuse.
And if you are capturing that as part of your
just good data practices, then that will help
facilitate re-usability.
However, at the end of the day, there is this
problem, which is that it's got to be, as
we say, buyer beware.
So
there has to be enough documentation to determine
whether the data is accurate enough, or valid
enough, for
whatever secondary use you might want to apply
it to.
So there's no magic bullet.
Sometimes you need so much detail that it
makes secondary use really difficult.
I think
if we improved our data hygiene as part of
daily practice, I think the idea is that would
help facilitate secondary use
of data.
So it's always just a good idea to think about,
if there are two ways to do it, it would be
better to do it the
way that might facilitate somebody to reuse
this.
And in any case, we still have the reproducibility
requirement.
So let's get second primary use of the data.
Somebody needs to be able to reproduce your
analysis, reproduce your analytics, so that
the results could be
validated.
Great, so another question which has come
up is a bit more technical.
So the question has to do with BD Bag.
And
they're asking specifically, how does BD Bag
differ maybe conceptually from what you might
have in your classic
TARS file structure from Linux?
And, basically, the idea with the manifests
that you have in TARS, and the
association information that's linked into
the manifests, could you provide some clarification
on that?
Yeah, so there's a couple of things.
One is the manifest includes checksums.
Not every file that's in the bag has to
be included in the BD Bag.
So we have the idea of embedded references.
So that's to facilitate big data.
There's a little more structuring information
about the file.
So, for example, the
name of the manifest is explicit.
It's actually one of the files in the bag.
The other thing is there is an RNC emerging
for bag structure.
It's not rocket science.
It's pretty simple.
It's just
saying, let's agree on some basic structure
of the manifest file.
What goes into the manifest?
How the data should be organized within the
archive.
And then let's build some
tooling that allows us to do things like generate
the checksums, generate the proper manifest,
fetch the data that
might be distributed, things like that.
There is a paper.
And there's a nice website with all these
things on it.
And if there's any questions on that, please
follow up with me.
Great, and last question really quickly, are
you aware of any particular resources, or
tools, to achieve FAIR?
Right, so there are lots of tools.
So FAIR itself is a set of principles.
It's not an implementation guideline.
So tools are some combination of policy.
So, for example, there's the ISA toolset,
that allows you to create
reusable data collections around investigations.
There are the various tools and services that
are emerging for
creating identifiers, like [INAUDIBLE] or
some of the other tools.
There are tools for helping create and do
annotations around metadata.
So I think there are things like Biocaddy,
which has been created in BD2K program, that
defines interoperable data models, and search
indexes, things like
that.
So there's no one tool.
I think it's awareness of kind of what goes
into it, the underlying principles, and then
being more explicit about your practice so
that you conform to these principles.
And, again, that practice could be, I know
it's got to go in a repository because that's
a condition of funding.
Are
my repositories organized around FAIR?
Or it's just like, I'm doing an investigation
in my lab.
And this would be a
good thing for me to do.
So let me think about, what is my strategy
going to be for findability?
And then what tools that are available could
I
use within my experiment to make things findable,
other than maybe coming up with a fancy file
name, or a
nested directory structure?
So that's what I would say.
So I think awareness is the first thing.
And then select the things that are right.
You don't need a sledgehammer
for everything you do.
So you could do just lightweight stuff, just
being cognizant as you design your
computational protocols.
Great, so we're at 10:00 o'clock.
I'd like to thank you again for this wonderful
presentation and some of the
discussion.
So thank you very much.
Thank you all for your attention.